the back-and-forth between Sony and
Disney over spider-man continued and it
seems like we have a different report
every day but today we have a little bit
more of a solid report as Sony has come
out and briefly talked about their plans
for the future of spider-man how's it
going everybody it's Warren and I know
everybody is getting really tired of
this back and forth we all just want a
deal to be done most of the fandom wants
spider-man to return to the MCU but
there are some people who would like him
to stay at Sony some people think that
if spider-man returns to the MCU and
venom follows him with carnage then
venom and carnage will be played down a
little bit to appeal to kids but at the
same time the MCU won't really be the
same without spider-man and as of right
now nobody really knows what's going to
happen Disney once tried to buy
spider-man back from Sony but Sony
demanded ten billion dollars for the
rights to the character Disney obviously
declined but now there are rumors going
around that Disney made a different
offer to purchase spider-man from Sony
again we're unsure as to what is going
to happen but as of right now Sony is
moving forward making their own
spider-man films Tom Holland still has
spider-man movies left on his contract
and Sony plans to continue to make
spider-man films so a break down Sony's
plan in this video quick reminder if
you'd like a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel and leave a like on this video
also if you'd like a chance to win a
Nintendo switch be sure to follow me on
twitter and click the link in the
description below so again as I stated
in the beginning of the video Sony's
plans right now are to currently move
forward with their own spider-man films
Tom Holland still has movies left on his
contract and he has already publicly
stated that he will continue to play
spider-man and Sony's plans for
spider-man are to put him in the venom
verse now this doesn't come as that big
of a surprise because we already knew
that Sony actually wanted Tom Hollands
spider-man in the very first venom movie
we know that Tom Holland actually shot a
cameo for the movie but Disney and
Marvel intervened and said they do not
want him in that movie the reason Marvel
did not want Tom Hollands spider-man in
venom is because they didn't want people
to think that venom was a part of the
MCU and that makes perfect sense because
at that point in time and currently
venom is not a part of the MCU Sony
still owns venom of course but now even
though Marvel and Disney are still
trying to work out a deal with Sony for
spider-man in the end
see you Sony still plans to move forward
making their own spider-man films and
weaving him into the venom verse and
according to reports in the past
Sony wasn't exactly impressed with Kevin
Feige feedback on venom and they felt
like he didn't really help much and then
venom turned out to be a really big
success so now Sony feels like they
don't really need Marvel and that
they've learned all they can from them
so the next spider-man films could be
spider-man and venom and then spider-man
venom and carnage we already know from
the post-credits scene of venom that
carnage is going to be making his way
into the venom verse and since sony
plans on introducing spider-man into the
venom verse it seems like we are going
to get a spider-man and venom against
carnage as of right now this is Sony's
plans if nothing changes if Marvel and
Disney don't make some sort of a deal
with Sony for spider-man in the MCU and
if another company does not buy sony
sony plans to move forward with
spider-man in their venom verse so let
me know what you all think about this if
Sony goes forward with their own venom
verse and introduces spider-man into it
will you be excited or would you much
rather have spider-man stay in the MCU
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again also don't
forget to subscribe to my channel and
like the video so you can enter my Xbox
one or ps4 giveaway as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof